in der britischen stadt leicester sind
am sonntag bei einer schweren explosion
zwei gebäude zerstört worden
die behörden sprachen von einem schweren
zwischenfall und hatten die bürger
zunächst aufgefordert das betroffene
gebiet zu meiden
alle verfügbaren rettungskräfte seien im
einsatz hatte es geheißen
über die ursache der detonation wurden
zunächst keine angaben gemacht den
rettungsdiensten zufolge wurden vier
menschen mit verletzungen ins
krankenhaus gebracht ein augenzeuge
berichtet das erste was ich gesehen habe
war das zerstörte geschäft und die
kaputte bushaltestelle auf der anderen
seite überall lagen trümmer und sehr
schnell danach brach ein feuer aus
bei dem vorfall wurden mehrere gebäude
beschädigt anwohner mussten in
sicherheit gebracht werden
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt gebe es
keine hinweise darauf dass der vorfall
einen terroristischen hintergrund habe
sagte ein polizeisprecher